this is what's left in one of the
coaches after the attack
hundreds of passengers on board
many are still unaccounted for
witnesses say the attack is open fire
after an explosion derailed the train
when they entered coach sp 17 they
opened fire and forced out the
passengers
one other passenger and i were found
hidden under a seat when they emptied
our coach they shot the other man who
died instantly i stood up and begged for
my life we were herded into the bush but
i managed to slip away in the dark
there was blood everywhere it looked
like a slaughterhouse many people were
shot
the train was only a few kilometers from
its destination
the wounded are being treated in
hospitals including this military
hospital
it's a second attack on trains in six
months on the same road
two days before monday night's attack
armed men referred to here as bandits
invaded the kaduna airport and prevented
an aircraft from taking off until they
were pushed back by security that
airport has been shut and trained
services have now been suspended the
abuja kaduna highway isn't safe either
in the past three years attackers have
kidnapped hundreds of people on the
highway many of them have never been
heard from again
an algerian president has ordered the
military to rescue the kidnapped
passengers and repair the damage track
for resumption of services i'd like to
assure you that those behind it will not
go unpunished
currently the men
and their chairs
and they will certainly pay the price
nigeria's military is currently deployed
to fight criminals in all of the
country's 36 states responsibility
security analysts say the police can
handle if they are given the necessary
support
kidnapping for ransom and unprovoked
attacks have disrupted agriculture
commerce and education
it has now spread to nearly all parts of
the country and security forces struggle
to deal with the problem muhammad idris
al-jazeera abuja nigeria